resuelve para x el valor absoluto de 2 x
5 es igual a 11 y qué quiere decir esto
bueno primero vamos a pensar en el valor
absoluto si yo digo que un número en
valor absoluto es igual a 11 y déjame
escribirlo aquí para que te quede mucho
más claro si yo digo que el valor
absoluto de am es igual a 11 esto quiere
decir que hoy es 11 vamos a ponerlo aquí
oa es un c en positivo en su dado caso a
puede ser también igual a menos 11
porque recuerdan que la función valor
absoluto lo que hace es cuando tomas
cantidades negativas las bases pasadas
positivas con el mismo valor es decir
multiplicas por menos 1 lo que tengas
adentro eso cuando tenemos una cantidad
negativa pues aquí vamos a hacer lo
mismo tenemos algo adentro del valor
absoluto igual a 11 esto quiere decir
que lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto o en su dado caso es 11 o en el
otro caso es igual a menos 11 así que
déjenme ponerlo aquí o 2 x menos 5 es
igual a 11 o 2x menos 5 es igual a menos
11 exactamente lo mismo que escribí aquí
del lado derecho vamos a escribirlo aquí
abajo
2 x 5 esto es igual a 1 cm
esto puede ser una ecuación o en su dado
caso también tenemos otra solución a 2 x
5 es igual a menos 11 y si te das cuenta
aquí ya tengo dos ecuaciones de las
cuales puede despejar la x por lo tanto
vamos a despejar x para encontrar las
soluciones de esta ecuación con valor
absoluto voy a sumar 5 de ambos lados de
la ecuación de esta primera actuación y
que obtengo 2 x 5 es igual a 11 si sumo
5 en ambos lados de la ecuación me queda
aquí 16 mientras que este lado menos 5 y
5 se van y me queda simple y
sencillamente 2x y ahora dividiendo todo
entre 2 me queda que x es igual a 16
entre 2 lo cual es 8 bueno esta es la
primera solución de esta ecuación con
valor absoluto ahora vamos a hacer lo
mismo con la segunda ecuación tengo 2 x
5 es igual a menos 11
si somos 5 podemos lado de la ecuación
me queda que 2x es igual a menos 11 + 5
lo cual me da menos 6 y ahora lo que voy
a hacer es dividir a ambas ambas partes
de la ecuación y me queda que 2 y 2 se
van entonces del lado izquierdo me queda
x mientras que del lado derecho me queda
menos
entre nuestro cual es menos 3 y bueno ya
tengo estas dos soluciones las cuales
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación
con valor absoluto y si ya que tenemos
estas soluciones pues sería bastante
bueno comprobarlo es decir vamos a
meterlas en esta ecuación a ver si se
cumple el valor absoluto si yo digo que
x vale 8 que me quedan dos por ocho
menos cinco esto en valor absoluto tiene
que ser igual a 11 vamos a ver si sin 2
x 8 es 16 menos 50 11 entonces el valor
absoluto de 11 es 11 y si se cumple
perfecto 11 es igual a 11 y ya tenemos
nuestra primera comprobación ahora vamos
a ver si el valor de menos 3 cumple esta
ecuación 2 por menos 3 menos 5 todo esto
en valor absoluto ahora tiene que ser
igual a 11 y vamos a ver si si
2 x menos 3 3 menos 6 menos 6 menos 5 en
valor absoluto tiene que ser igual a un
su positivo y después menos 6 menos 5 es
menos 11 el valor absoluto de menos son
se tiene que ser igual a 11 positivo
es el valor absoluto de -11 es 1111
positivo es decir que 11 es igual a 11 y
también cumple así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo